[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN CHONG: All right, cool.
My name is Ben Chong.
I'm a product manager
on Cloud Storage.
I have with me today
Manvinder Signh
who is responsible
for all the technology
partners and special
guest Ralph from Veritas.
And so today we'll talk about
building cloud storage that
spans on prem to the cloud.
I know we use the
word hybrid here
and it means certain
things to certain people,
but just put it aside.
So it's kind of like hey
the zombies are coming right
so Zetabyte age is coming.
The 44 Zetabyte
number is probably
familiar to some of you.
I think Cisco commissioned
a study a few years ago
that they focused for cost
about 45 Zetabytes by 2020.
So we have a new number today
is 180 Zetabytes by 2025.
So the question really is how
can we manage storage, how can
we hold that much data,
can we manage and store
the data in the traditional
way in your data center.
Even with compression
and duplication and so on
we are still talking
about a lot data.
All right so the question then
is, OK if we want to use it,
store this data in
the traditional way.
Do we go on a spending spree
and buy all the storage
where we can get.
If that's your plan, let
me know and I'll buy shares
in HP and [INAUDIBLE] and on.
So why not leverage
cloud storage?
Right.
Essentially when you
leverage cloud storage,
Google will take on the owners
of dealing with capital costs.
We will deal with the
operations and all
that so essentially you are
able to store more data more
quickly.
So essentially, when your
amount of copies of data
increases if you want
to handle and manage
that all by yourself,
you're basically
racing against that increase.
So Google we can do that
much better than you
because we can
leverage it across all
the different customers across
internalization and so on.
Going hybrid but it also
helps reduce complexity,
because as you buy
more hardware you're
talking about multiple
platforms, different vendors,
different software and all that.
Whereas with cloud essentially
with Google, for example,
there's one single platform.
The single set of API,
single set of tools,
a single vendor to
yell at essentially.
And this is a pitch for
Google Cloud Storage.
I mean the key words
there are robust,
seamless, and also
simplicity, and low cost.
I forgot, let's save
questions to the end,
we have lots of
slides so that will
help us get through things.
And this is our
storage portfolio,
we have basically two
storage tiers or classes
for live or frequently
accessed data.
And two storage classes
for infrequently or cold
infrequently accessed
or cold data.
So there's
multi-regional, regional.
Multi regional
essentially means that we
are going to store the data
across multiple data centers
in continental locations.
But a US EMEA or
APAC region would
mean that you would store the
data in the set of data centers
that are on the East Coast
US or West Coast and so on.
And depending on your use
cases, how frequently you
want to access the data whether
your consumers are continent
wide or regional you may want
to store the data differently.
Multi-regional versus
regional and then
also depending on your
frequency of access
you can decide to sort.
And then Nearline or Coldline.
More details here, we talk
about pricing and so on.
I think the key things to
note here is the redundancy.
When you talk about
[INAUDIBLE], so multi-regional
we are talking about
more than two regions.
Two regions are more.
Separated by at least
a hundred miles apart.
Regional, Nearline, Coldline
come within the region.
There's performance as
well, which is interesting.
So we talk about first
byte, the latency.
So it is very different from
lot of our competitors, we
when call this tier of storage
has an access penalty where
if you want to access
the data you have
to wait three to five hours.
I think that's fine if you
are used to retrieving data
from [INAUDIBLE], but
for a lot of use cases
you want to get the data
as quickly as possible
because you want to do
a request and then wait.
So the data is available
like within milliseconds,
is essentially the same platform
technically so you don't have
to worry that OK I start my data
in code here and therefore I
have to wait hours and I cannot
achieve the performance that I
need to get the data
as quickly as possible.
The other thing that
is very unique to us
is a consistent API.
So across the different
tiers is essentially
one API single set of tooling.
If you are writing
your own tools,
you don't have to
worry about Oh my data
is in code line I need
to access it differently
versus everything else.
Here's a slide about our storage
locations, our data centers.
The square boxes where we
have data centers today,
the blue boxes are where we are
planning to open data centers.
So in multiple regions,
increasing number of regions.
So we Know for
example customers may
want to keep their data in a
general locality in the region
or a country for
whatever reason.
So we are opening more of
these mini data centers.
The yellow dots are
our points of presence
so it is basically measuring the
distance between where you are,
your data center, your
company to the nearest
point of presence so that
kind of reduces data latency.
And that's very unique
to Google because we
have a lot more
points of presence
than the competitors,
a lot more network.
Here we basically highlight
the different kind
of multi-regional packet
so US, EU, and Asia.
Here we want to highlight
that the cost of cloud storage
is always going down.
We kind of highlight
that from 2011
when it was slightly less
than $0.175 I believe.
Now is all the way
to the lowest year
$0.07 gigabyte month
and as we optimize
the infrastructure will
pass on the cost savings
to our customers.
All right so question, how do
I start using cloud storage
in a hybrid?
So I'm going to hand
over to Manvinder
and who will go into
a lot of the details.
MANVINDER SINGH: Can
you guys hear me?
Awesome.
Thanks, Ben.
So now the session is about
hybrid storage scenarios,
but as Ben was talking
about our product portfolio
I just noticed that all of
our products are in the cloud.
Ben and I don't talk
to that often so
that's why I just noticed that.
But the point is, that is
why it's so critical for us
to work with partners.
We do manage data on-prem
or help move that data
between on-prem the cloud.
And as we go through the
slides I'll talk about some
of these partners
and how they can
help us solve these use cases.
All right so, what are
these hybrid scenarios?
So we thought we will pick three
of the most common scenarios
or three very common
scenarios that we
see our customers
asking us about
and walked through some of
the challenges they're facing.
How we're solving
them, what partners
are helping solve
those and we'll just
go into details of those.
So the first one is we're
calling bursting but there are
lots of different names but
essentially the idea is you
have your storage on-prem, your
data which has a lot of gravity
sitting on-prem but you want
to use the cloud for compute--
the transient compute cyclical
compute jobs, bad jobs,
any bursty kind of workloads.
So we'll talk about that.
The second is your classical
set of use cases around backup
and disaster recovery and
application continuity
and those kind of things.
So we'll talk about
those in today's session
will go deep into
backup and then
talk about different trade-offs
and then those things.
And then finally, we are
hearing more and more
of what our customers
want to actively archive
their primary storage
for the cloud.
Expand the storage
that they have
and then save money
in the process
so they want to use cold
peering to that cloud.
So we'll talk about that.
All right so bursting.
So as I mentioned, we
have a lot of customers
who for various reasons want
to keep the date on-prem.
Whether that's
compliance reasons,
it's internal company
policies but it's really
cost effective to leverage
compute in the cloud
and especially high
performance compute jobs.
Example would be
a hedge fund that
has a lot of transaction
data but they
want to run monte-carlo
simulations in the cloud,
understand their risk
profile and that's
a classical use case
of when you can burst
your compute into the cloud.
We also see a lot
of M&E studios is
doing rendering
transcoding does kind
of compute jobs in that cloud.
So the key thing
here is how do you
move that data close to the
compute instance in the cloud
and move it to wherever
you want after that?
And we work with
partners in those cases.
Great example, a top partner for
us is a company called Avere.
So what Avere does is they
provide the virtual appliance
of your VFX that can run
in the Google compute
instance and the customer
that has data on-prem in a NAS
or an object storage you can
cache that data in the cloud,
run your computer in the cloud.
That is obviously very
common but we're also
seeing a lot of
customers that want
to move that data into
Google Cloud Storage, object
storage in the cloud and
Avere has a physical appliance
that basically is a
gateway that can do that.
So that's essentially
cloud-bursting from the cloud
perspective you also call
it reach back to on-premise.
You're basically reaching back
to the data that's on-premise.
So moving forward.
So backup and backup
to the cloud right
so the backup with the
cloud has been around
for many, many, many years and
it's been talked about a lot.
Yet not all the data is
backed up in the cloud
and there are good
reasons for that.
What we are seeing an
acceleration in that,
and we believe that it's
going to accelerate even more.
And then there are
several reasons for this.
Number one, Ben talked in
detail about data growth
and there's just so much data
that needs to be backed up.
And you need limitless
amounts of capacity for that.
Fixed budgets.
So you have you you're
basically trying
to do the backup without
increasing the budget
or trying to do more
with less all the time.
And then progressive CIO's
want their IT priorities
to be aligned with what
the company outcomes are.
The company goals
are and managing tape
is not super high
in priority always.
And then obviously
security and compliance,
even for your
secondary storage data
you want your data to be secure
you want it to be compliant
and cloud provides
a way for that.
And so, if not cloud
the other options
are obviously tape and disk
and let me just quickly touch
upon those.
Tape is obviously
inexpensive, it's
very widely used, it's used very
often for long term backups.
But it comes with its
own set of challenges.
So it is slow, it's
often stored off site,
and I'm preaching to
the choir here for sure.
But it is slow, it
is stored off site,
it can take several
hours for you to restore
or several days
for you to restore.
And then it's manual.
We had a customer which had
10 plus petabytes of data that
was basically backups that
they had done over the years
and they wanted to know how
they can move that to the cloud.
The big challenge was
based on the resourcing
they had done the
math and it would
have taken several
months for somebody
to just read those tapes.
So it becomes a challenge,
it's a manual steps.
And then whenever you
have lots of manual steps,
Murphy's law comes into effect
and it's always error prone.
And then disk is less manual,
it's relatively easier
to manage, but it is expensive.
It's not meant for long
term durable storage
and it doesn't scale that well.
So that is why we believe
in backup to the cloud
and we obviously have
a vested interest
but we believe that cloud
comes with its advantages.
For example, reliability as
Ben said with cloud storage
all the storage classes come
with 11 kinds of durability.
So you don't have to
worry about your data,
losing your data,
high availability.
Cloud storage almost never
goes down, at least for Google.
And security, so you
can encrypt your data,
you can manage access
control and you
can get all the benefits of what
Google is investing in security
and then making sure we have all
the right safeguards in place.
But it often comes down to cost
and our customer engine team
has developed essentially
a backup calculator that
can, based on your scenario,
based on your trade-offs
do the math and then
indicate what might,
whether or not cloud
is a good option.
Because you have to look
at several costs including
upfront Capex
capital outlay costs,
the personal cost, the
recovery cost and there
are advantages to
each storage media.
All right.
So how does backup work, what
is the deployment architecture
and these are two of
the most common models
we've seen with our customers.
The first one I guess you
can call it the direct model.
You You're using
a backup software
whether it's very task net
backup or something else
and you can use the
built and integrations
to back up the data
directly to the cloud
and we'll talk about
that in more detail.
And the other model
is you can essentially
use a storage gateway.
Which you can point your
backup software to and then
you can use that storage gateway
to move that data to the cloud.
And we see that as a
common model as well.
That's very helpful if your
backup software doesn't
integrate with the cloud
for whatever reason,
you can always use a gateway.
All right so to talk more about
using your backup software
and the introduction and let
me hand over the mic to Ralph
from Veritas and let's
hear from the experts.
RALPH WYNN: All right, can
you guys hear me over there?
Unfortunately, I
don't have the mic
so you aren't going
to get the data
dance that I had
planned on doing today,
so I apologize for that.
So first of all, Ralph Wynn,
I'm a principal product manager
for net backup.
Responsible for our
cloud vision and strategy
and when I tell my kids
what I do I say well
you know I help customers use
the cloud more efficiently
and so that sometimes they give
me that look and they say, OK.
Well, I show them
the presentation
that I was doing for
Google they're like,
oh OK, so you're going to help
Google protect their data?
I'm like no.
I'm going to help
customers use their data
and put their data in Google,
so it's made heavily available.
And he goes, my youngest he
goes, what does that mean?
I said, well, basically
it's like YouTube,
you can use YouTube
on any device.
Well, you're going to
have your data available
across the world from an
enterprise perspective
and he goes, OK cool.
So if he understood that
then hopefully you guys
are going to understand
that as well.
And so for us from a
Veritas perspective,
we have three distinct
use cases that we always
talk about especially
when I'm talking
about the cloud there's actually
four but them talk about three.
When customers are
looking at how do
I really start to utilize the
cloud and my infrastructure.
We really start off with
storage and for us it's
all about how do we give
customers the ability
to take their toe and dip
it in and start to move some
of their data into the cloud.
And so for us we adopted
cloud connectors for Google
to give you the ability to use
both of those Cold and Nearline
storage tiers that Manvinder
shared and Ben shared,
because that's
really what customers
wanted us to really start doing
it's easy for them to adopt.
And then next thing the
question is, OK, now I've
got my data up there well I
want to start running some more
workloads.
Well, we have the
capability now which
is part of the announcement
is that we certified Google
Cloud to run that backup.
So that means you
can go out and pick
an instance, a type that you
want, utilize the operating
system that we support
from that backup
and easily rollout and
that backup server.
Now of course, the next
question is when is net backup
going to be in the launcher?
Well, we're working
on that, we're
going to have that
available here
shortly so that you
can actually roll out
net backup from the
marketplace within a matter
of a few minutes and
in any region you want.
And then number three is
how do I use the cloud
or utilize these gateways
to help me really move
that data a little quicker?
Because what I've heard
from customers of all
shapes and sizes is that
we have petabytes of data
that we want to
move to the cloud,
but we don't have the
bandwidth to handle it.
And so the cloud gateway is
definitely a great option
for those customers because
they can break the streams up
into multiple different
segments and send data up
to the cloud and
the frequency that
matches their bandwidth
and also their SLAs.
So for us this is
really the way that we
see working with Google
to give you guys,
especially if you're
looking at how do
I really jump into the cloud.
These are the options
that are out there.
Now as far as how do I
really get started with this,
the goal for us from net
backup perspective is
don't take you out of the user
experience that you're used to.
You're used to creating backup
jobs inside of net backup,
you're used to creating
storage devices
and if you're not in that backup
customer shame on you guys
it's the best product out there.
It rocks, it takes
care everybody's data.
Of course I have to say that
because this is my product.
But when we looked at how do
we incorporate cloud storage
into that backup it was all
about the user experience
and so what you're
seeing are just a couple
of examples from the UI.
You say I'm going to
add cloud storage,
you're going to find Google,
you're going to pick your tier,
and then from there you can
specify your credentials.
Simple is that we go up
make the connection for you,
we're already optimized
to send data based off
of the parameters that we work
with Google to not only break
up our data into
the right chunks
but also the compression
and encryption capabilities
that we know that you guys
need for this type of data.
And so it's a super
easy configuration,
most of our customers
love the fact
that they don't have to
go outside of net backup
to incorporate Google's
cloud storage capabilities.
And now with our
partnership it's not
only just about data
protection but it's also
about giving you
the full 360 data
management access to your data.
So hopefully you've heard
about our 360 data management
platform that we're
working on here at Veritas.
The value that
this really brings
you, especially from Google
perspective, is you're
going to get that insight.
You're not only going to
know exactly what data
do I want into the cloud versus
the data that may not even
be cloud ready or may
be data that shouldn't
be in the cloud such
as the company picnic
pictures from 2016 that really
don't need to be in the cloud.
So have that
insight to that data
and then be able to have the
capabilities to use cloud
as a DR target,
those are other areas
that we're working with
Google, with other products
in our portfolio, as well
as having the ability to do
copy data management.
And so that is all about
giving you the true end
to end capabilities
with data, give you
the insight and to be able to
move that data into the cloud
tier that you want.
Be able to use that
data for other analytics
that you may have,
and then also use
the cloud as a recovery target.
So I'll turn it back
over to Manvinder.
MANVINDER SINGH: Thanks Ralph.
So we were worried about
Ralph jumping around the stage
so much, we didn't give
him a lapel you give him
the mic on the stage.
See the key takeaway here is you
could use the best software out
there with the software that you
already use to start backing up
to the cloud.
Another key takeaway is we're
seeing our customers back up
from all kinds of sources,
all kinds of applications,
and service to the cloud.
Another example of a
partner, Cloudberry Lab.
Their software allows
customers to back up
your SQL, your exchange
servers, your device endpoints
if you have a Mac or a Windows
machine, you can back that up.
You can even back up
SaaS applications,
so GSuite or Office 365.
So diverse sources here.
And before I wrap
up and back up,
one interesting use
case we are seeing
is a lot of our
customers are running
mission critical
applications in the cloud.
Often behind those
applications they're
running non-sequel
scalable with databases
like Cassandra and Mongo.
And then we're seeing
them use backup software.
One of our partners
Datosio they're
using the software to backup
to Google Cloud Storage.
All right, so moving
on from backup,
let's talk about tiering
or active archiving or cold
tiering to the cloud.
And as I mentioned, creating
tiered storage is not new.
You typically have a highly
performant active storage tier,
you may have a
less active storage
tier that's slightly cheaper.
And then you may have some
archival storage tiers,
an online one an offline one.
And we believe that as
you go from left to right
in this picture, cloud becomes a
very viable option for actively
archiving your data.
But how do you do it?
So a couple of years,
you could either
use an on-premise
storage platform
that has this
functionality built in.
My example is cloudian which
provides on-prem object
storage.
And then they can tier this data
to the cloud based on policies.
Yet at the same time maintain
the metadata on premise
and provide a global name space.
So that's one way to do it.
And there are many,
many of our partners
that have this functionality.
I think EMC is here
in another session.
If you're using
something like Quantum
or one of the other object
storage or NAS platforms,
tiering is often an
inbuilt functionality
but you could also use a
gateway to do that tiering.
And let me talk about comprise
which does that but more.
So Comprise is an analytics
driven data management platform
that basically in
a few minutes you
can get full visibility into
all your on-prem storage
and you can understand
based on policies
how much ROI would
it give you if you
moved those data to the cloud.
And it can move the
data to the cloud
without disrupting your
existing workflows.
And I'm going to
hand it over to Ben
but before I do that, if
you're interested in Comprise
I believe they're doing a free
assessment for Google customers
to understand what kind
of a ROI can result.
BEN CHONG: All right, thanks.
All right so this conclusion.
All right so the question then
is, what and when to move so
you can see the kind of criteria
to move data to the cloud.
Data that is older than 30
days so data that's less
frequently used.
Data that is in branch
offices that you
may want to move to your
own central data centers.
Now since this data is going
over the network why not
move them to the cloud.
Secondary copy.
So cloud is very popular
for secondary backups,
so you may have a primary backup
somewhere but a lot of times
you want to secondary
backup somewhere else
in a different location
managed by different people.
So cloud is a very good
destination for that.
Tape replacement we've
talked about that.
So depending on
the kind of data,
tape replacement may
make a lot of sense.
And one of the things that
we didn't quite mention
is there are companies
whose secondary
value, they have a primary but
the secondary value is the IP.
One, you want to
protect your IP.
You need to access your
archives and all that
on a very frequent basis.
So rather than keeping this
data on tape with Iron Mountain.
And then when you want
to retrieve for discovery
you need to pay
them a little money
and you know there's
a lot of lee time.
Why not put all this
data in the cloud
just like Fosdick says faster
to pull out, fast recovery
and you get really
good value on the data.
And that goes to data
with locked up value.
Also data supporting
local business
continued data recovery,
so all of this data
is better in the cloud
because one of the things
that we talk about replication,
we do all of that for you.
We have had sessions elsewhere
where customers would ask us
for, I need to worry about
where I should start data
geographically.
Well, guess what, we cannot
take care of that for you.
Whether you choose
Multi-regional, Regional,
Coldline or Nearline that's
kind of implicit as opposed
to having IT people think
through all that stuff
and I'm kind of
worried that no I'm not
replicating my data correctly.
So when to do all this stuff is
typical catalyst events right
where your equipment is going.
You know obsolescence, where
you need to do, structure,
upgrades, or where you
have a new CIO they say,
hey, we need to go
to the cloud first.
OK that's a good way to get
on cloud because backups,
you move to cloud storage it's
safe, there's little risk,
and you can always say that
hey we are cloud ready.
All right so in
summary, so essentially
what we're trying to
say here is that there's
a whole ecosystem of
partners to support you guys.
When you want to do these
different scenarios.
Whether you're doing this
thing, back up or tiering.
And then what's next for you?
So talk to your rep, your Google
reps about upcoming solutions.
So the road map in place that we
cannot disclose or NDA so talk
to your reps.
Contact us for a tape
versus cloud calculator
so we'll talk about pricing.
Like Manvinder was
pointing out, try
the Komprise free assessment.
And importantly go downstairs
to visit our partners at expo.
So all of them are there,
go and talk to them
about how they can help you guys
do hybrid and tiering to cloud
storage.
So really this session I think
that there's a big large scale
data session tomorrow Friday.
That's my session.
And then if you
guys have missed it,
there was an earlier session
that talked about cloud storage
but the content should
be available online.
I think it's going to
be on YouTube after this
so you guys can look
into it and dig deeper
into cloud storage what
that means for you and so.
[MUSIC PLAYING]